All right.
We're learning that
Lisa Marie Presley
will be buried at Graceland in Memphis
next to her father, Elvis Presley,
and her son, Ben.
A family spokesperson
made the announcement Friday.
The only child of Elvis Presley
and Priscilla Presley
died Friday after suffering
cardiac arrest.
Presley had a music career of her own
but was probably best known
for her marriage to pop
superstar Michael Jackson,
as she was also open
at times about her struggles
with addiction.
Lisa Marie Presley was 54 years old,
passing away this week.
Let's bring in Alana Nash.
She's a journalist
who has written several books
about the life
and times of Elvis Presley.
Including The Colonel,
The Extraordinary Story of Colonel Tom
Parker and Elvis Presley.
So good to see you, Alana.
Thank you so much for having me here.
So I'm wondering,
what was your reaction
when you heard the news of Lisa Marie's
passing
Oh, deep, deep sadness.
It really shook me,
I think,
not only because I had interviewed her
and been around her a little bit
and enjoyed her music, but also just that
the Presley story is one of,
you know, great opportunity and wealth
and fame
but that just equals
sadness and trauma and tragedy
that balance that out.
And I think we wanted her to be happy
and have a joyful life
because her father had
given us so much joy.
So there's there's deep sadness
about her passing all over the world.
Yeah.
And since you had an opportunity
to speak with her
on so many occasions, and,
you know,
and you talk about how collectively
everybody want to be happy and be joyful,
but then what
did you sense
from her in your conversations with her
about what was keeping her
what was
in the way of that joy and happiness that
everybody would wish for her?
I think just the
crushing weight
of fame, number one, and loss and grief,
you know, the
there's a lot of a long line of loss
and grief on on her father's
mother's side.
And it seems to be continuing
through the generations.
I think she always wanted
that sense of peace
and family unity and search for that.
Loved being a mother,
loved
being part of the rock and roll world,
but just
could not find lasting happiness.
She she loved it.
But at the same time,
was she all also kind of disdainful
you know, of
the celebrity, especially learning
as she has over
the years
about the people surrounding her dad?
And she was a part of this.
This latest, you know, blockbuster film
in which, you know, she got to enjoy,
you know, the actor
getting a Golden Globe this week.
But there was there was something
that also made her very uncomfortable,
angry, if that's the right word.
Or you better describe for me
what what she thought of, you know,
the world of entertainment
Well, she was certainly
an angry little girl.
And you see that
in a lot of her photographs.
And you certainly see it
when she became an artist.
And again,
writing songs,
those those songs are just filled
with acrimony and bitterness,
but also with with a really sardonic
black humor,
a kind of sense of humor
that balance that out
made it very appealing.
But she was never really comfortable
in public.
She loved the fans.
But she
she looked
at fame
as a thief that stole
everything that mattered.
And so she was that she was always
jumping and. Wow.
And at the same time,
did she feel like
I mean, she was compelled to also
just try her hand
at having a relationship with fame
by being a singer herself?
And if she felt like she had to do that?
Or was it like her?
I mean, was it her feeling that
she couldn't,
you know, part from that,
you know,
because of the legacy of her dad?
I mean,
what was it that compelled her
even though she had this disdain,
also say, well,
I'm going to also reach
into my musical roots and try my hand
at that end of fame.
Well, it was a part of her.
While she was enormously proud
of being
daughter
that wanted
to step outside of that shadow,
you see that,
I think in her marriage
to Michael Jackson, King of Pop.
You see that
perhaps in her brief marriage
to Nicolas Cage,
but also to
two men
who were not involved
in high stakes business.
But she was a deep and true artist
like like her father.
But of course,
there was no real escaping that shadow.
And then and then it sounds like there's
no escaping the loss
and the grief
that you were just describing to
with the suicide death
of her own son, Ben.
What kind of impact did
that make on her life?
She said it destroyed her.
And, you know,
I think that's probably right.
You see this
dichotomy of her,
of a lot of strength of character
but fragility.
She always seemed
kind of like a lost little girl
who needed a lot of protecting.
And that increased with the death
of her son
in 20, 20
And, you know, he looked a lot
like Elvis as well.
He knew Lisa. My gosh.
What she does was it eyes and bright
blue eyes and beauty Oh, my goodness.
I mean, it is so shocking and sad.
I think
even this many days
after the fact, it's still,
you know, really hard, you know, to
to to understand you grieve for her,
you know,
and the more we're learning about what
she has been
through her entire life
after her
dad's passing at the age of nine.
I mean, it's
just been so traumatic on so many levels.
And you helped really fill
in a lot of blanks for us.
Lana Nash, thank you so much.